and we're excited to announce a new  relationship this morning between CBS  News and BBC News our organization's  will share video editorial content and  resources the Alliance will strengthen  both networks commitment to original  reporting around the world  the BBC reports from 125 cities in 70  countries and reaches a weekly global  audience of 346 million people so we're  building on a relationship forged by  legendary CBS news journalist Edward r  murrow during world war ii he delivered  many reports from a BBC studio in London  later Murrow was given the microphone he  used at the studio so full circle we  have come here at CBS News and the  tradition of Murrow producer now he has  not only Murrow boys but more Murrow  girls here